autres victimes de ces inondations
dévastatrices les animaux exemple avec
ce reportage de vincent du yen et de
l'udc bachofen au sud du mans où la crue
de la sarthe a entraîné l'isolément
total de près de 200 têtes de bétail ici
on traverse les champs en bateau à roëzé
sur sarthe le fleuve est passé en
quelques jours de 50 mètres à 2 km de
large
des exploitations agricoles se sont
retrouvés complètement isolé pour
atteindre celle ci il faut compter une
bonne demi-heure depuis la terre ferme
les propriétaires ne sont pas partis car
cette ferme abrite aussi tout leur
bétail
aussi depuis le début chaque jour les
pompiers les amis et même l'armée
viennent leur prêter main forte
parce que le mercredi elle mardi matin
si les vaches avaient péri c'était la
ruine assurée pour cette famille
d'agriculteurs 80 têtes de bétail dans
67 vaches laitières plus le matériel
ça représente impossible d'évacuer les
bêtes et secours ont dû se contenter de
les tenir au sec en surélevant les
tables avec de la paille
d'autres agriculteurs membres de ce
qu'ils appellent la mutuelle coups durs
se chargent de la très belle adulé donc
il faut absolument faux l'entretenir si
vous l'avez dit oui j'allais vous faites
par exemple trois ou quatre jours
ensuite alors qu'une neige fine et les
militaires quant à eux s'employer
aujourd'hui à nourrir le bétail et à lui
constitué un stock suffisant pour
plusieurs jours car même si le niveau a
tendance à baisser
on attend de nouvelles pluies alors on
se souvient que mieux vaut prévenir que
guérir et se méfier de l'eau qui dort